this is a production of Cornell
University hi everybody my name is Pete
Johnson I have a farm called Pete
screens in northern Vermont zone 3 zone
4 we're way up there started as a tiny
little 2 acre you know half acre farm 20
years ago now
my experience with cover cropping up to
about 4 years ago was sort of typical
vegetable farm you know throwing some
rides throwing some buckwheat here and
there and then I decided to go and find
enough land to have three or four times
as much land as we crop on we crop about
100 acres and we have about 400 acres in
rotation now of varying quality some of
its not great but just jumped into this
big experiment of trying to learn about
technology
just learning about cover crops in my in
my talk will just basically show the
experiments that I've been involved with
for three or four years now different
pieces of equipment on different cover
crops things that I've learned things
that I realized I know almost nothing
about and have a ton more to learn about
it now way more fun for me than growing
vegetables it's super interesting the
growing of the vegetables is sort of
just a proof that you did a decent job
with with the prep time we're also
trying we use a lot of raw chicken
manure and other bulk soil amendments
and we're trying to get our soils fully
up to speed ready to roll in the cover
cropping period before vegetables start
and that's still a couple years away
from really being there but it's the I'm
seeing lots of good promise for that
we've taken a lot of land that was sort
of real old plate out land brought it
back and two or three years of lots of
fertility lots of cover cropping has
really been successful is this is this
slide showing it must be okay can you I
how do I get back at the beginning again
so we're going to go at a certain pace
apparently
so I started off thinking I'm gonna do
I'm gonna do like two years sod it's
gonna be my program legumes grasses and
I did a bunch of that for the first
couple years this is an example of that
thank you
lots of red clover all sigh clover the
best grasses for us seemed to be fescues
real aggressive growers but I'm not
finding that after this my soil has
really transformed the ways I want it to
it doesn't seem like a gain enough like
bulk organic material some cases we've
been hanging this some cases we've been
mowing it back in in all cases I haven't
been super impressed by the results so
now I'm basically doing that with land
that's really got some issues needs to
be locked away for a while
this is buckwheat this is a mix that we
had this summer sunflowers buckwheat
there were some peas in there whole grab
bag oats some plant or more this is
perhaps the most important slide this is
300 pounds an acre of oats and fern
talked about tried-and-true stuff
earlier my hot weather you know sue Dax
things like that hardly grew for me this
summer it was so cold and wet where we
are
oh it's day in day out I can get to
crank 300 pounds an acre no matter how
we the field is I basically get a clean
stand every time and that's super
important that's probably the most
important factor for me in what I choose
to you feel free to ask questions at any
point because this is a just a grab bag
so we're going to do more and more of
you know cheap seed high high rates a
whole bunch of organic matter production
in a short period of time this is a rye
vet that was knocked down and that's
what it looked like before we knock it
down we're gonna still stuff this spring
for the first time we had a no-till
drill it was has struggles doing it
without having some weeds in there and
made me kind of think it's not really
going to be our future necessarily
because just a little bit of established
we'd from the previous crop really
becomes something serious in the next
crop we played around at caliente
mustard this year just aiming at weed
killing weed seeds I'm not sure if it
worked well I'll show you the regulator
that we used to incorporate it
it was difficult without doing a really
careful trial to tell I don't know what
that is that's my farm down there in the
valley Craftsbury
it's half an hour south of the Canadian
border in the middle of the state this
is the mix of I was telling John Paul
earlier I son hamp this summer it got
about 8 inches tall it's in here
somewhere
I was really excited you don't see this
huge massive legume and it's just in
cool wet conditions that just didn't do
anything that's me pointing to a sunhemp
plant down down there so it's it's
really interesting how something that
could be awesome one year especially in
a climate like mine is not so great some
other time there's some pictures here to
show how even this great high seed rate
mix like this there is pigweed there's a
pygmy plant right in the middle there
and that's a serious problem and that's
you know in a rotation like I'm working
on it I really can't have that I'll show
some tools later that we're using to try
to prevent that it seems to me like with
mixes I have a lot to learn about the
species composition the rate the timing
what time of year it is to make sure
that doesn't happen here's um a place
that was no-till knocked down right at
seated into it it's trying to show that
there's some weeds in there we actually
use buckwheat a lot in the summer like
wolves will seed a sod crop grass and
legume right through the summer and
we'll use buckwheat in them in a
midsummer period as a weed suppressant
for that it's much more effective than
oats at that time of year
buckwheat sat about 40 pounds an acre
will basically keep weeds from going to
sea
newly seeded side crop more pigweed in
this mix that had stood ax and all these
things and this was carefully prepared
land that was tine weeded before seeding
the cover crop some flowers a lot of fun
first year i grown them this year we had
lots and lots of tourists checking them
out I like that biomass I'm seeing off
it
the seed is cheap if you buy birdseed
rather than you know sunflower seed seed
and germination seem to be good this is
always the thing you got this stand you
look down in there you know this was a
super weedy vegetable land had been kind
of abused for two or three years and you
got those weeds down there you're like
okay what are they gonna do are they
going to make seeds or not and that's
the critical question and it really
depends on how quickly things fill in
and cover in this case probably yes
because there's gum globe in there and
it'll usually make seed wherever but in
the 300 pounds acre of oats very very
little maybe none this was a fun thing
we got this summer we've been trying to
do a mulching project for a number of
years where we make round bales and then
blow them onto vegetable plants yay tall
and we've we've now played around four
different round bale choppers and none
of them cut the round bales quite short
enough so my neighbor had this forest
chopper that we bought for 3,000 bucks
and this was ride that's you know he ate
all that we've kind of forgotten about
and had to grow vegetables in this field
and of course there's nothing you can do
with it at that point doesn't matter how
many times you've hair it
so we mowed it with the hay mower and
then chopped it and blew it over the
field and I think we hit this stage just
right it was you know fully in grain but
still quite green and the fertility
production from this for the vegetable
crop was really impressive and I don't
think it was from the veg because there
wasn't that much veg it was the Rye
really released a lot of nutrients and
it was a fast step didn't take very long
and that land was just ready to go and
do great crops start into equipment we
know that was chopping wind rose but
we've what we've discovered now is that
when we're doing our our mulching we
have to forage chop and then spread that
with a manure spreader so we take dry
round bales or we take we take dry
windows forged chop them it's basically
a silage operation at this point and we
haven't quite figured out the details of
that but that spreads really well with a
manure spreader right over very small
vegetables cuz it's only an inch long
and it falls off at all everything we
were all the round bale choppers are all
two and a half inches plus and that's
just a bridges over the crops these this
is a new us we call it a speed disc
formats a Czech company really slick
tool we have a lot of rocks in our area
we're constantly breaking gang bolts on
disc harrows this is the tool that's
designed to be used at 9 miles an hour
it's very fast this is showing it
incorporating two-year-old grass legume
sod that you know historically we would
moldboard plow
three passes with this thing at 9 miles
an hour at different angles in the right
conditions if the soils moist at the
right level and you can seed a cover
crop into this three to four passes over
the course of three weeks and you can
see vegetables so this has become sort
of a super critical tool for us we had a
different version called a Lemkin this
is much cheaper the parts are much
cheaper the speed is tremendous when you
have a lot of acres to cover and each
disc is individually as an individual
spring on it so they just roll over
rocks with no
no problem at all really long-term more
established saw it takes some more
passes in three to four but still with
the speed it's not a not a big deal
we went and got a range rail with six
inch spacing this year because we had
one that was seven and a half and it
wasn't doing wasn't planting stuff close
enough this was a nice addition although
I think we're gonna go to broadcasting I
wish I get back up could you take me
back the bidding and that could shuttle
through again sorry that farm at Machine
just gonna keep going no back to the
equipment part sorry
there yeah thank you so yeah I can't if
I was smarter I could do that couldn't
so this cedar is not very useful that's
a cedar on there drops the seed right
here right behind the dish right before
the rollers but it's way too small so we
are looking at either pulling an air
seeding cart behind this or having a
much bigger air seeding tank on the
front three-point hitch of the tractor
somehow to you know be able to carry at
least a ton of seed and I like the idea
of this because I'm not going to have
rows at all
I'm gonna have a uniform distribution of
seed we we're demoing this and playing
around with it just to see if we liked
how it covered and it seemed like the
main concern is it likes to cover the
seat a little bit too deeply sometimes
but you could adjust the depth of these
discs with these rollers here it seems
like it has a lot of potential and we
can now be seating at 6 7 8 9 miles an
hour rather than you know 5 with the
grain drill maybe 6 when you're covering
several hundred acres and doing
sometimes multiple crops and the same
acres every year speed becomes important
so these things come with a variety of
rollers this is a really heavy one that
packs the soil more
main drill this is our little cobble
together setup for a corporate in the
mustard
so we flail mode it and then just
seconds behind
we disc arrow then coltie packed it
seemed to work fairly well this is a 30
foot lei Li tine weeder and we time with
a lot in our vegetable production we
almost don't plant anything without a
week and a half to two weeks of every
three to four days tine weaning as a
stale seed bed practice so I thought boy
I'll do this on large scale for cover
crops and it'll work great and it didn't
work that well and I can't I'm not
really quite sure why this spring are
time we did a field for three weeks
prior to seeding cover crops I think it
was just too cold and wet nothing was
growing at all at that point because
when I seen my cover crop I still had a
whole lot of weeds come in so it's
probably just a timing thing but I'd
almost rather just use a much higher
rate with with some cheaper crops and
and deal with it that way because you
have to get out and about with this
thing but I think it's a tool that has a
lot of potential for cleaning up some
ground before seeding a cover crop to
try to keep weeds from coming in but we
haven't really found the sweet spot with
it yet this is this no-till grain drill
we has actually a minimal till this is
the Caddy that went in front of a
regular grain drill and these Coulter's
made slices if anybody's interested I'm
also learning how to do my own tiling
that's a tile plot of the left hole
another saga this is the grain drill
that went behind that Coulter cart this
was kind of a big cumbersome thing hard
to turn around you know slow to pick up
eat use quite a bit of horsepower to
pull it
besides it's not maybe the final
solution okay hopefully will blow up
here at some point I'm stuck they won't
let me move about to restart yeah what I
found and I haven't done it enough to
really be sure but it seems like those
large seated things if you let them go
to sea and let them sit on top of the
soil for the winter I have not had
problems when I incorporate them I
sometimes do but that's kind of cool to
learn that you can you know dump all
this stuff on top of the soil and let
everything eat it all winter but I have
friends who had a lot of problems with
buckwheat doing that so I don't know
that hasn't been an issue for us it's
nice because I like to grow I like to
have buckwheat as a component of some of
those mixes and of course it's going to
seed so this is that Loompa Firth
rolling Harrow this is a really cool
tool it's just these bat well we have
these there's little scraper blade
leveling blades or leveling Levellers
that's it in front of those baskets and
then little times they're off it right
now and then two sets the rolling
baskets this thinks 30 feet wide and so
we were worried about making really
smooth hay fields for a while because we
were that's sort of was our plan early
on we're gonna be hanging and making all
this mulch and stuff and this is a
really important tool for making one
pass of this makes land you know fairly
rough land pretty darn smooth it's also
great if you're broadcasting cover crops
to incorporate you can also stale seed
bed with this it works really well
rather than the tine weeder every pass
with it just makes things smoother and
nicer and better this is 5000 bucks out
of Quebec in good shape really awesome
tool cover a lot of acres in a short
amount of time this is another speed
distance is the Lumpkin Rubin this is
the one we got first we went away from
it because the parts are
real expensive and you're gonna go
through disks and bearings and it just
seemed kind of crazy how much they cost
I've got a power here a couple years ago
it
we actually have broken a lot of sod
with this - in places that are too steep
to plow doesn't do great in rocks really
great for finished touch over vegetable
crops just another piece of the
component in France they seed a lot of
green behind power arrows seems to be
the standard practice over there there's
a there's a you know grain drill mounted
behind the power Harrow really easy just
two pins on a roller so you can go
really fast and really shallow
you can go eight miles an hour and just
be skimming along or you can really
really good it's a very versatile tool
it's just it's much it's better tool if
you don't have a lot of rocks so we tend
to use it in certain fields
not another ones speaking of rocks Rock
rake we got we've took on 70 acres a
couple Springs ago that was a corn
ground I mean I think it has a rock
resource there the the number of cobbles
like this is just infinite and we were
able to seed really nice alfalfa grass
down by making one pass with this thing
and then we had another machine to pick
up the rocks and this also leaves a
perfectly smooth finish for for seeding
versatile tool these ill the round bale
mulching because I kind of think of
mulching it's kind of an extension of
cover crop but you think about no-till I
think about all the different things you
can do mulching is sort of like moving
moving cover crop from one place to
another this is a real simple old-time
Bale chopper it's more of a flail the
flails just kind of beat around this it
doesn't actually cut the grass at all
but it throws it out it's really good
for garlic and strawberries things were
you're just kind of doing bulk mulching
it's really fast simple tool not a lot
to go wrong
this is the best one we found for
actually cutting quite short this is a
has it two different chopping systems in
there takes a lot of horsepower it's
pretty slow it's maybe a bail every five
minutes four to five minutes you don't
wanna have any rocks or going like that
and your bail it's got to be nice and
clean different purpose this is what we
were trying to use to blow onto the
vegetable crops and it actually works
well this does chop it fine enough that
it works pretty well it's just a pretty
slow step and I'm not sure if we're
going to be incorporating it into a lot
of our acreage or not thanks
this is I'm just learned about these
this is an air seeding cart and idea is
to pull this I have a 20 foot wide one
of those fireman's coming and idea being
we could pull this behind that and be
seating into the far mint with it it's
kind of a big cumbersome thing but I
could go out with 4 tons of seed and
something like this and you know not
have to come back and refill this would
be like for a bulk like 300 pounds an
acre oats stuff like that so if anybody
has any experience with with this or an
air seater like this I found this this
is in England but it's a big you know
big tank where the seed goes and then
those are just shanks where the seed
comes out they're five inches apart so
it's really close spacing that's a 24
foot wide machine but I got to get away
from the 12-foot wide grain drill which
is taking too long for the land we're
covering and this just survived today
this is this is what we're gonna pull
the 20 foot new speed disc with because
I want to spend more time with my
daughter unless time on the tractor and
these things are cheap I mean the
horsepower like this is super cheap and
we're moving towards speed you know
quick passes shallow passes fast passes
you know incorporated it get something
else on so sort of like our version of
no-till is lots of quick shallow passes
not bringing up lots of weed seeds from
below lots of different cover crops and
different sequences and as you can tell
very much a learning process that's it
for slides questions comments
[Applause]
top secret yeah
12 grand 360 it's crazy
biggest tractor I have is 140 horsepower
it's also 13 feet why just gonna be
interesting on the roads but but we pull
implements down the road that are 15
feet wide but there's something about
the height that scares people right out
front my neighbor is restoring a Porsche
and I told him this is going to come
into a shop we're gonna paint this first
to like say it but this I get this sort
of thumbs up like how we do things we
kind of go online learn about it figure
out how to buy a version of it that we
can afford bring it home try it
sometimes they work out sometimes they
don't but you don't know until you get
it home and you always learn something
interesting and it just informs the next
step of the process yeah
oh of course that varies a lot from you
know if you're sitting down I saw alpha
grass mix it's gonna be 45 50 to 70
bucks for the seed sometimes I'm going
organic here sometimes I'm not depending
on whether I can get it you know it's
the 300 pounds of oats I can get done
organically for 55 to 60 something like
that the Sun hemp was an expensive
failure you know and that's the question
I often ask myself you know is is three
crops in a season you know if I have a
piece of ground I'm really trying to
break up a weed seed cycle and I might
want to actually have three cover crops
in the course of a season to have a
little tillage in between am I gonna
spend a hundred bucks per seeding there
it's probably totally worth it but I
don't really know that math I don't
really know what makes sense
I have vegetable crops that gross
forty-five thousand dollars an acre so
sure why not but it adds up you know it
starts to seem like a lot of money my
sense is the more you spend it's totally
worth it
you just sized for us it's a new part of
our budget we're kind of getting used to
so it seems like our seed costs just
keep going up and up but I think the
benefits are really there
so what's your like typical rotation
you're in vegetable in the field but Cup
well what the the grand plan was 2 years
veggies in two years in a sod crop but
I'm finding that in my second year in
veggies I'm not getting the performance
I want so I'm looking now mostly at
one-year veggies and land that's in
really good shape probably one year's
veggies one year cover crop sometimes
the one year in cover crop is more like
a year and a half you know how all this
stuff kind of goes around the circles
but I actually have enough land here I
could basically be one year in veggies
two years off three years off in some
cases and I have some I have some land
that still is recovering from being over
crop for a while so it'll be off for
three years
but I'm finding that in that second year
no matter how good a job we did the
first year in weed control I start
having some weeds going to seed in the
second year and we don't we don't spend
hardly any time hand weeding on in my
farm very very very small part of our
budget so it's either controlled with
tractor cultivation and pre pre
treatment or it's not really controlled
so I like I like land that's just
first-year and veggies after not being
in it for a couple of years it really it
solves a ton of problems and it makes
all this stuff seem cheap in comparison
yeah but that was but but that was
created though by deciding to make that
happen and I know it can't happen
everywhere maybe but I think
well you know sneak them in wherever you
can but I would advise trying to I see
great benefits to from a rotation that
goes a mile or two or three miles away
you know potato peels for us are a real
problem and if we can move our 10 acres
of potatoes a couple three miles away
it's really a lot better so we've gotten
really comfortable we travel 20 acres or
20 miles right now to one farm we've
gotten comfortable with the travel and
the trade off of that prepared to have
it everything closed we wait well we
won't be cropping down there for a
couple of years but yeah I mean it goes
23 miles an hour why not right yeah I
don't know we we don't irrigate there's
another thing so for us to move around
we haven't irrigated outdoors in 7 years
partly that's our climate partly it's a
lot organic matter residue in the soil
so we're not so tied into an
infrastructure we can go and get a new
field and farm over here so it's sort of
like we're sort of like creating these
landscapes around that are in prime
condition for vegetables and we sort of
- it and grow a crop and get out of
there again that's how I think about it
and that is leading to a fairly low
input fairly low cost production system
that seems to be working for us but it
still no three years before everything
kind of is fully online and make it all
work the right way I thought I was gonna
first but then the the turns out the
fertility suck up of hay is enormous so
even even just to replace the nutrients
that's taking is about two-thirds of the
value of the hay and then there's
nothing to screw up trying to grow
vegetables than having a major hang week
going on because it's the same guys the
same equipment when you're hanging
you're hanging I mean you're not do
anything else and we actually love
hanging it's super fun we get all
excited about it but so now we're mostly
flail mowing stuff back down we make we
have a pig farm as well so we make a
whole
around bales for it but they come back
onto the land and I think if you were
doing like a small round or small square
bale premium organic hay thing you can
make money doing it but you'd have to be
set up for it and it's just not it's too
too wet where we are to that it's hard
to try it so we actually had to buy we
have a mower with metal on metal rollers
in order to crimp the legumes well
enough to get legumes dry at all for our
mulching hand for our pig Hey
because we're trying not to wrap bales
that was a critical piece of equipment
we couldn't get red clover to dry period
otherwise so that's helped a ton with
that yeah beside it's fun this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at cornell edu